welcome to this video coverage for round
six of the sink filled currently held
and st. Louis USA yay around six after
five rounds we have a careworn are
leading the field with five out of five
yeah very outstanding performance and in
this round round six we'll see if we can
continue his winning streak yeah I look
at all the games this time really
looking at one game a little bit more
detail the two others a bit a bit
briefly let's start with Nakamura
aronian yeah they both have really
rotten tournament let's see if they can
do something in this game to to improve
ya na can work with 14 and we get them
Berlin yeah aronia does not play that so
often he mostly plays 86 more one and
going from for more complex some middle
games um gather Berlin of course now
White has a choice he can play d3 our
key pieces on board or go for the ending
now camera I'm going for a third option
not playing d for here which leads to
the famous berlin wall ending this this
thing on there also is the rookie one
and this is what he played this is some
one of the lines that to be honest a
little bit deters me as from from
playing the Belinda's black and some
games i just i considered looking at
this opening for black this is one of
those lines where you actually never
ever going to win a game with black you
are probably not going to lose many but
it is a very very solid choice for white
there should be seven we need to block
the e-file and now nakamura just went
back to everyone yeah black has some
various possibilities you can also play
with no def
ever disc the same position he exchanged
now and castles the reason why this is
some ya know so I'm so boring in a way
is that it's a lot looking like a
forensic French exchanged where both
sides have Castle short like deform d5
sometimes happening in this game d4 d5
didn't happen because Nakamura tried
something really funny he went to d5
quickly and now look to e2 very young
yeah very original set up after c6 he
went to e3 yeah the idea is ready to
play night f5 and going to e7 we will
see that this is really happening the
Queen e1 yeah note that d 5 i'm is
punished by this funny move so Bishop f6
and now on I dare 5 so he has lost the
ton of time for this maneuver but at the
end check he managed to get to e7 with
the night and trade off one of the
bishops so white here has won the bishop
pair but yeah well look at the position
those bishops are not exactly great at
the moment they are long-term asset but
pretty hard to to activate it looks like
um yeah somehow white has has not
developed anything he's got everything
in the first two ranks and black has
pretty decent pieces you will now
activate Queen and the night will come
to a six so I think that this should be
about equal this position um black has
some very good piece coordination to
compensate for for the bishops plus at
the moment the bishop in for example
coming here we'll just look at this pawn
why you're here nakamura played
something really extraordinary he played
Queen to a5 attacking a seven the wrong
yet simply ignored that as Queen a seven
can be answered with
amongst others with 95 um we can look at
this and say here black has on let's say
you you capture first also possible get
the tempo and then something like this
is going to happen this is leading to a
very good compensation for black
something that white definitely does not
want to have yeah what did become what I
do he played just remember he just
played Queen a five rupee eight he went
back to you one that's really a really a
funny maneuver it costs him lots of time
probably being frustrated what he just
did there was a funny tweet but hey
Garry Kasparov who wrote that didna
camera really just play Queen a5 and
back to e1 ? this is all too subtle for
an old retiree yeah okay I don't know
it's it's hard to hard to understand
maybe he with Queen a five he really was
thinking he could take the pawn and it
it after all seem too dangerous Tim BB
we can maybe if you're not convinced
look at this a bit more yeah Queen we
have maybe rupee eight from us them
Bishop m390 for this kind of thing this
can easily easily lead to a tube
troubles for white he has nothing
developed something like this for
example is a very very problematic
initiative yeah c2 hangs if you play a
slow moves like like this for example
check your going to get attacked very
very severely h5 is just one move here
but a strong one I white really should
not risk this so queen e oneness
relatively speaking probably one of the
better moves yeah but here with black
even even I'm gain this time Queen a
five he won back he should have no
problems yeah we got to this position is
quite interesting with d 4 + c for loop
bit of an s
symmetrical transformation black
definitely has a good player he's got
the deep on and in no bad piece so he
has nothing to worry about they still
play left before an interesting booth
intending maybe rook b1 b3 to activate
the rook and down Aronian quickly played
actively with d3 yeah activating here
rugby one route 28 and now we have D 2
in the mix yeah Bishop d2 to stop that
and Bishop g5 yet this blockading bishop
should be traded now black has enough
counter play a text here and the tech CM
I want to play because the d3 poem is
very likely to get lost so you need some
some compensation for that we now got
those trades in and at the end of this
black will take him yeah this position
is is just equal white has a slide
symbolic advantage with the bishop he
would also get one of the points back of
course but it's nothing serious at all
this was played g 6 a-2 need to get some
some look for the king go to g7 Bishop
c4 check and now we saw those traits
yeah Queen e6 something that also does
not lead to anything yeah black gum can
easily can easily hold this yeah
something act like this I'm sorry this
was this was of course wrong need to go
here to have them check wind e7 if
there's a check on the 7th this is in
fact something that white shouldn't
shouldn't go for his black ass got the
airport it's in the drawer but no use to
do that yeah they played like that I
think they can put some music to draw
now yeah so a game that in a way shows
that this is not Nakamura's
the screen a five Queen Queen greenback
business is really quite quite funny
yeah but the position is just so stale
that even with wide losing this time
there wasn't really going on much so I
think a pretty correct correct draw here
okay next game will be Carlton against
mvl maxima Sheila Grove let's see what
the word champion can do the only chance
that he still has to to do something
against kawana winning the tournament is
to start winning now so let's see what
he what he did play down eform and we
get with some transposition we get an
accelerated dragon it's a little move
order vanessa was 93 and the ellis
playing the the night off of course
usually and for night of player Knight
c3 is a slight issue you need to play d
6 or a six to get to the night off as
you don't want to commit the knight to
c6 and after d6 White has some
additional ideas with f4 for example so
this is a little little drink but okay
this is some line that is very much
playable for black as well so here we go
yeah after the game I think maxime
stated that he had confused move orders
here he wanted to play Queen 85 here he
had to to force basically wide to Castle
but he canceled first and only now
played Queen a five and here White has
some additional ideas for example what
Carlton played with f3 it's nothing
dramatic but it it's sort of God he
stumbled into this position without her
knowing it too well okay we quickly see
that he really has some he really hasn't
studied that that much it seems here
after a takes d5 it seems that black
should play Knight takes d5 which seems
a little bit counterintuitive to
exchange pieces but it has one
very distinct advantage if you look at
this position here why it is lacking the
natural move Queen d2 to connect rooks
and coordinate the whole army this is a
problem now for white I'm problem
relatively speaking he should probably
play something like this and now black
can for example go to e5 and this is
okay for black yeah he has this night c4
ideas and it's not clear how wide is
going to increase the pressure in short
order in the game we took with the pawn
and after Queen d2 black is already in
some trouble the problem is that this
Queen position allows all kinds of
tactics and we see this we see the soon
groupie 8th route d 1 and now he played
Bishop d7 which allows one of those
mentioned tactics it's so ever difficult
to recommend them yeah something
something I'm elds are much much better
it's it's really a bit difficult already
and also it's not so clear how bad the
whole position is well he played Bishop
d7 and after that cards now started um
started the technical operation he took
now Bishop takes is answered by Bishop d
4 which is a very very one-sided affair
White has a very nice blockade and has
chances to long-term exchange those
bishops it's a very very young
uncomfortable position yeah white can
even think about playing something like
Queen f2 and sometimes push the Jeep on
its map it's it's a bit of a risky
business but it can be considered white
also just can pile up on d5 he took with
opponent this this year allows one of
the operations that I mentioned Knight
takes d5 very typical thing with the
Queen on a five being unprotected now
black has no choice he must take on d to
check Knight takes bishop takes bishop
and at first it looks like there's
nothing going on as black takes on be
too however white has a has a point and
the point is bishops III that's a very
strong move and the only reason why this
is something that white should go for ya
black must take this this desperado
Bishop no choice and then you could be
seven and here we have a typical
situation these two pieces put enormous
pressure on the f7 pawn and black has a
hard time to defend him as his Bishop is
basically am yeah a spectator it can be
placed let's say on b6 and I think it
appears there later but it does not
attack anything while white is always
piling up here on f7 we see this this
happened it's very logical it's clear
that black is on the ropes here I'm very
very difficult to defend in fact my
initial reaction when I saw this
position okay this is a 10 it will take
time but caliber would somehow win this
as he is so great and now in technical
positions um and we see that this one in
a way it was pretty much a smooth
sailing for for quite a while it feels
very natural black was giving up this
pawn okay he has no way to defend f7
anyways I get get to this and air here
by the way black went to 2 h8 if he goes
to h6 the big problem is that something
like H form and possibly g45 is a mating
net this will be very very ugly and
possibly not defendable this is why went
to 2 h8 which is not nice of course you
don't want to place passively however as
bad as this looks it is not very
clear-cut how white should win now it is
of course very much better for white but
you don't really you cannot really point
out a very clear winning plan um I think
that causal played all the obvious moves
mean at least obvious looking to me yeah
we continue a bit activated yakking
Kenya all this looks normal here King c4
looked a bit bit more normal than King
be too but it's probably not much of a
difference at the end yeah he pushed his
pawns and this this looks looks also
very normal g5 is an idea to set up a
meeting net yeah let's say to
demonstrate if blackest is simply
ignoring everything here there is
checkmate this mating idea one reason
why the pawns earn were advanced in the
first place to set up this black must
must fight against that and went for
rogue h2 and we now get a trans trans
position or let's say transposition is
wrong transformation yeah why does
attacking here the sea porn and we have
now exchanges on the King side this was
played yeah this is a good move that
attacks here and make sure that black
gets a passer on his own now White has
to pass pawns the f porn and the C porn
but black has the H porn and it's a
think I'm something that black ball
comes that he has some some source of
counter play with the age pawn you don't
want to have a purely acid in sit and
wait position where you can do nothing I
think around around here we need to
start to look for improvements form for
white I mean this this looks very normal
putting it only for rogue h1 and i'm not
i'm not really sure where cards now went
wrong so I'm doing a little bit of a
spoiler here what he played was not
sufficient to win be done typically he's
probably the greatest technical player
player around but he didn't he didn't
manage this maybe it is not winning it's
possible but
I'm not really sure I can tell you one
thing let's look at the game he went f4
look at 3c three yeah black pushed the H
porn and with this H pawn push he had
enough counter play to finally get to
get the rooks traded and ultimately with
the king and the promotion get the e
pawn this is a very long yeah this is a
law sequence of 12 moves but it unfolded
pretty logically with age for being
pushed and H porn ultimately getting
traded for the F porn this end game this
arising end game is definitely a draw
there is absolutely no winning chance
for white we can look at this at the end
so somewhere in this sequence of moves
from here to here there must be a some
way to improve because if it is not
winning for white definitely there must
be some way to make it make it harder
for black to defend while I was
analyzing us also looking at at that
statement of the players or something
sometimes they give some some some hint
after the game what they were thinking I
couldn't find anything substantial other
than that Carlton was thinking he should
have a win somewhere but couldn't really
point out at which at which point at
which point and also found that there
was less than there were comments by a
grandmaster alejandro ramirez and he
said that he didn't like the moves f
form and and f5 that white should have
oops sorry why should have this pawn on
a 3-2 have the base for the bishop this
is very much true very often you want
you want those supporting at pawns for
your for your for your bishop and then
maybe this also can be a good blocking
piece on the fourth-ranked so that white
might advance the Seaport so this is
possible maybe those moves F for later
fi
whether what the source of yeah source
is wrong but what causes why this game
ended them ended in a draw but it's this
is a very difficult thing with limited
time to determine how should or could
white how could white why doing here
let's look at the final the final of
endgame we're here the age porn and the
e porn were traded yeah why is this a
draw we can look at this because at
first glance it might not be so apparent
as white it's going to walk to a six and
even win the a porn the problem is it is
a fortress I can put up the executive
draw position here here they agree to a
draw and this is a situation where we're
even engines are completely yeah then
they don't understand the position it's
still it's still the case this is
totally dead but if you give it to stock
fish for example it would still give an
advantage for white substantial one and
it's totally dead yeah King a8 is very
easy to understand their black is just
shuffling yeah this this Bishop is
always covering a seven and white can
can push all the way here and it's just
a shuffling till the end ok so to a six
then okay blank is still shuffling and
the problem is you never get anywhere
this Bishop is always staying on this
diagonal and white can put up the porn
here a six and we're still shuffling and
you can give this that the engine over
here I've stopped for sheer depth 60 so
plus 1.6 okay it's just the total draw
white will never ever advance the pawn
and yeah this is somehow this this game
game ended certainly very disappointing
result for for Carlton he is really not
in great shape he wasn't at the Olympiad
it wasn't terrible at the lumpia but it
also wasn't good
two games there and this event is not
not much better maybe it's really very
much distracted by the the issues around
upcoming we're not upcoming you don't
know what championship match okay now
the game by the tournament leader kawana
playing to par love ya to pull off
certainly a bit of a joker in this
tournament he had played good
enterprising games and and really
terrible games to be honest it was a
rollercoaster ride let's see what
happened here kawana playing efore as it
usually does and we get an open Sicilian
with a six yeah this is some an
interesting line for black them this
move has gained some popularity in
recent years they normally just played
Quincy seven then the tomorrow of
variation this has some yeah this is
still a very popular line but the rise
of the Bishop e3 Queen d2 f3 set up even
here in the terminal has let black
players to to to to look for four
different muth orders and a six is a
move order that is quite interesting
against this Bishop e3 f3 set up as the
queen is not committed to c7 yet this
very often is an important little detail
for black however a6 allows a different
variation and this is the capture this
is what kawana played um it's a bit
uncommon to take on c6 and the Sicilian
and in the vast majority of lines it's
also not very promising he however it's
it's a bit of a difference and one point
is that the move a six is not very
helpful here for black in this structure
basically has lost a move with a six and
very often you could argue that it pawn
would be better on a seven um however it
is nothing that black should be afraid
of I mean it's it's a normal position
okay we get some normal developing move
luckily one Bishop e7 or very normal
yeah um no II 597 cringy for this it
seems has been played before and the
part of now played the King to f8
nowadays move like that is not yeah it's
not something that is very very
surprising let's say that people give up
their nuh castling right the older movie
is g6 which has been played them in the
majority of games Bernard for example
King f8 however is a move that also
kawana played he played this move in the
loop yet only about a month ago against
the grimaces Oh luck from Turkey and he
played a draw at the end and he also had
this position I'm earlier as wide
against us witla could lend g6 however
in in in June so what about King evade
is this a good move yet it's certainly
an interesting move and we quickly get
to a crisis night a four is played yeah
this sir might look a bit weird if you
don't don't know this this line but it's
a fairly typical way to play as white
wants to have to lose the c-4 available
to worm to nibble at to head the pawns
and he also needs to have something if
black plays c5 you want to have c4 as
well quit a5 was played and here karana
played the move rookie tomb yeah this
was some afterwards I mentioned to be a
new idea this rookie to it once you look
at it it looks fairly fairly logical
white wants to prepare beauty to it also
hence a bit on on the up coming up
coming line a tribe was played twin f4
and g5 that's very enterprising approach
very typical of the parlor and of course
it makes some sense to play that once
you have played king evade yeah if you
wanted to play something like g6 you
could have done that the gun done that
earlier and not play king a raid one big
point is that wide of course he has to
do something about this night and he has
no square for the Queen so he plays
Bishop d towards a funny technical point
of the rupee to idea here's the first
critical position it seems that here
black could have taken on f4 yeah let's
look at this black could have taken
Bishop takes and then a move maybe like
group g8 or H form now this is in fact
interesting it looks somewhat weird
because the pawn on f4 it looks like bit
disconnected from black sir other pieces
but he has some activity going and with
the porn being on air for the e5 pawn
also needs some attention so this might
be a really a really decent position for
black I think it what also was also
mentioned by Kerwin afterwards that this
was a definite term alternative that
black could have played to pull off
didn't do that he went for Quincy seven
which might not be bad but it was an
interesting alternative to go for the
capture Queen g3 age for plate and Queen
g-form yeah and I think the next move is
the the cost of to palos trouble later
in the game I can be be that that
I can tell you that was as much of a
spoiler he played rook g8 now and this
turns out to be really really bad it
seems the first thing to notice here is
that night xe5 is not possible yeah you
cannot do that because of this rug in
the corner however h3 was an interesting
alternative that leads to two very
double-edged plane it's a yeah it's a
bit crazy but interesting if white now
captures black at the end will take here
and yeah probably will have some
compensation yeah he's got the the H
file open and maybe a long-term really
can can get something going especially
if you consider that the white three
maybe will not stay on g5 all the time
let's say we should be seven sometimes
King g7 to g8 this is something and note
that bit should be 75 d for the long
diagonal is something that the black
Bishop will definitely am yeah be happy
to occupy um that's interesting that's
an interesting position and wide also
had g3 after a tree and here we have an
interesting situation black here can
play Bishop d7 something like that but
you can also think about it's very risky
but can think about taking one point is
a net here d form if white now takes
with the bishop you have the honey move
385 which threatens made it's a very
difficult thing to see beforehand but
funnier funny motif yeah a tree is
probably the justification of black oak
legs play but this is some sometimes
happening tu t'appelle off is playing so
am aggressively and so let's say yeah
it's very often he reaches the point of
no return where he needs to find those
absolutely only continuations that keep
the
keep the the flame burning in a way and
he sometimes does not manage to do that
if he's when it's not in top shape he
went rook g8 now and now while play
truck 81 yeah centralizing and this
pretty much um is the the completion of
the rookie to idea now he five is very
securely protected and it's very
difficult now to see any counter play
for black the queen on g4 is blocking
the King side there is no h3 I just take
that with the Queen and what exactly is
blacks plane what he tried is is
probably right see 5c form and the
capture to get the diagonal open I think
white is some is better here in any case
because here you really don't see any of
any compensation for the for the
somewhat fishy King position yeah where
is your your active play here but okay
it's not a lost position but black
really is under under lots of pressure
h3 a good prophylactic move yeah making
sure that h3 is never really happening
and they'd give some some look for
working rook the eight bishops III
supporting the pawn Knight to d8 air to
be a time sorry yeah the night on this
happen wasn't doing much and maybe we
get it get it here rookie three and here
we have the absolute key position of the
game while black is clearly not in great
shape it is still not still not clear
how wider is going to continue if black
now would have played Bishop d5
combating this Bishop on c4 why it is
definitely better but it's not apparent
how he should should win quickly like b3
for example you just have the better
structure to pawn islands against
against three weaknesses so white is
better but not not a win it would still
be a
but hard day's work um however to pile
of plate 96 and when he played 96 he
overlooked a tactical detail koala now
it took took some minutes and then took
only six of course T'Pol off had seen
the move this is a very obvious move
it's the first move that any good player
would consider in the position but he
made a calculation mistake in the lines
that that follow he took on his six now
what else are you cannot let the bishop
stay there check and after who gave
three what he had initially planned it
was not working the power of thought
that he could go to g7 after which Queen
h5 is very obvious threatening
threatening made rook f8 until he had
overlooked the point rook f6 Andrew k f6
is the finishing touch to this line here
why does of course totally winning yeah
something like this check adhere white
check and take with a win or if you want
to be very cruel you even have this move
threatening 96 which is quite quite
strong as well but Queen g5 is simple
and good yeah he had overlooked this
roof look f6 idea and then all of a
sudden saw that okay you cannot go to g7
you must go to e8 and this is definitely
not where you want to be with your king
yeah kawana now just took only six and
yeah this attack is simply super strong
the rook here is a text and yeah where
should it go it's a very difficult if
they look let's say moves to age 82 to
start with this Y term simply can take
on c5 yes the bishop pinned so see if 95
controls d7 and your threat is simply to
play Queen g6 and curtains yeah that's
just just devastating
something like this check check wins the
Queen yeah I and the rook really has
nowhere to go with this attacked he
needed to go to g7 he did he did that I
mean Duke g7 was played and now Queen h6
is the point the rookies attacked and
yeah what should black play in the game
he played 94 but there really wasn't
wasn't a good choice anyway if you go to
g8 by the for example white place is six
and now threatened screen age five and
and over yeah something like the check
checkmate does it meet the king is just
killed killed in the middle of the board
yet a part of tried night to deform the
last term last attempt to continue yet
here White had had a number of wins you
can also just take on g7 this is for
instance green g7 90s porn takes and
hear that Tech is simply too strong I
mean you need to see that why does not
even sacrifice something is to bonds up
and end has this attack let's say King
d7 chattox check oops and we should be
five those kind of things are simply
resign double yeah Queen g7 was was
winning but kawana took took some
minutes and then played the the the
flashiest move played e6 yeah it's a it
not net it's not necessary to do that
but you have the time to calculate and
are confident then why not e six wins
sorry this wasn't intended threatens
queen age eight made it to and black
really has nothing else he needs to take
on f3 yeah it's something like it's just
too simple there is no no reason to to
go for for something like that check
check check
yeah what can also just just take yeah
by the way it's a piece up everything is
this too much yeah she took them and
played them Bishop to to f8 and ya hear
the game concluded with a check kimia
seven only move Bishop g7 a TM to pile
of resigned facing the line Bishop g7
Queen sm king d6 and d7 yeah what a
beating yeah it it really it's really
happens if you play a very very sharp
and a double edged position and you you
make those I mean Brooke g8 was was not
good and then it's yeah you place this
burden on yourself to find those moves
like like Bishop defy if that need to be
played and won one further misstep
really needs to do to the defeat like
here yeah in very nice game but Kara
wanna but certainly a bit helped by bite
Apollo who stumbled somehow into this
preparation it's a bit bit bit
surprising considering that if you
notice that this is this was played by
by Caruana as black so he definitely
needed to have some gas in preparation
for him playing this is black it is
clear that kawana knows quite a lot
about it if he wenches this with black
so bit surprising that he he didn't have
any any big recipe here after rookie to
ya note that that he played if you look
at the time this was played very quickly
but now he he started to think which
seems normal for 444 hacia but for those
top professionals you really should have
some idea idea prepared against rookie
to you could ask the questionnaire what
else I mean rookie 2 s's might be might
be a new idea but what else should I
play it's um it's much more
interesting move let's say then c3 or
something like that I mean well c 3 is
probably not even possible due to the
a49 yeah okay now what can you do karana
six out of six this is taking taking
historic proportions six out of six in a
super top level event is very rare and
this being the at least buy rating
strongest tournament ever makes it all
the more remarkable yeah he's very
clearly the world's number two at the
moment in terms of terms of rating and
in this shape very serious challenger
form for the world title um but okay he
might get his short later we have a hard
time to predict how the world
championship title legacy will continue
as it is very unclear cars will defend
in Sochi and after that it can get
really messy if once again we had this
this two World Championship issue
earlier okay so thanks for watching I
hope you enjoyed this coverage and I'll
be back with round seven of course
tomorrow thanks